هذه الحرب على وشك ان تدخل شهرها الرابع
ومع ذلك كتائب القسام والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره على الاشتباك مع
الجيش الاسرائيلي خلف خطوط التوغل واطلاق
الصواريخ من داخل قطاع غزه نحو غلاف غزه
والمدن والبلدات الاسرائيليه ما دلالات
ذلك السي الدخول العسكري لا يعني نهايه
الحرب يعني اليوم عندما يمكن استمرار
اطلاق الصواريخ على الداخل الفلسطيني
المحتل او داخل مدن الاسرائيليه هذا امر
مقلق لا اسرائيل حتى لو انتقلت الى
المرحله الثالثه يعني طوقت مدينه غزه
انشات المنطقه العازله سيطرت على الوسط
وبالتالي طوقت مدينه خان يونس اذا استمر
اطلاق الصواريخ هذا الهاجس سيكون كبير
وسيلي اي انجاز يمكن ان يحققه هذا هذا
الجيش الاسرائيلي اطلاق الصواريخ يعني
اللوجستيه موجوده القرار موجود سريه مكان
الاطلاق والقدره على الاطلاق بالرغم من ان
الحرب الدائره وامكانيه مراقبه القطاع
ليلا نهارا من المسيرات من الاقمار
الاصطناعيه من التنصت وما شابه قادره على
اطلاق هذا الصويخ هذا يعني وكما قال
البارحه جون كيربي ان حماس لا تزال قادره
على الموضوع اما السي موضوع الهجوم على
خلفيه التقدم الاسرائيلي في هذه الحرب لا
يوجد جبهات يعني يوجد الخطر من اليمين
الخطر من الشمال الخطر من الامام من
الوراء من الابنيه العاليه ومن تحت الارض
هذا ما يميز الهاجس الاكبر للجيش
الاسرائيلي وياخذه الى موضوع المعنويات
ليس هناك من جبهه وهنا قدره المقاومه على
القتال من عده جبهات يعني عندما نقول هاجم
في خلفيه ايه الجيش الاسرائيلي هذا لا
يعني انه فعلا خلفيه جيش اسرائيلي لانه
المقاومه موجوده في خمسه ابعاد اهمها
الانفاق وهنا السؤال عن الانفاق عميد
الياس حنا ماذا يقول لنا هذه المشاهد التي
رايناها لعمليات المقاومه لاطلاق الصواريخ
ماذا يقول لنا عن فعاليه العمليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي انها تستهدف الانفاق لا سما في
خان
يونس
قرات البارحه باله ارتس مقالا يقول لا
تكذبوا على
الاسرائيليين لا يمكن تدمير الانفاق
الانفاق تتطلب استعلام تكتيكي السي وهذا
الامر ليس متوفر الجيش الاسرائيلي اليوم
يبتكر انوفيشن يعني يبتكر وسائل وتكتيكات
معينه كلما تقدم وتفاجا بما يجري على
الارض يعني عندما نتحدث عن 500 م لا ر حتى
الان الا الشيء البسيط منها هو يستعمل
روبوتات الكلاب يستعمل الكلاب المدربه حتى
يستعمل الطائرات الكوت كوبتر كما يقال
لتذهب
ضمن الانفاق وانشا وحده خاصه يعني كما
يقال اون جوب ترينين هو يتدرب ويستكشف
ماذا في هذه القاف الانفاق كلما تقدم و
هذا امر صعب جدا في الحروب يعني لا
استعلام ولا تكتيك والدليل على ذلك
استمرار القتال على كل الجبهات واطلاق
الصواريخ ا وهنا ايضا السؤال عميد الياس
حنا يعني اليوم ما زلنا نشهد قصفا
اسرائيليا لكل مناطق قطاع غزه ماذا يعني
ذلك بالنسبه للاستراتيجيه المتبعه في هذه
الحرب في مرحلتها
الحاليه ال ال القصف هو حيث المازق يعني
حيث يريد تسطيح الارض للتقدم اليوم
غزه مدينه غزه حاله معينه محاوله فك
الاشتباك للانطلاق الى مرحله التطويق
المعارك الكبرى اليوم تجري في الوسط حول
المخيمات ماذا يسعى الاسرائيلي هو سيطر
على طريق صلاح الدين ويحاول عزل المخيمات
عن بعضها البعض تطويقها وتقطيعها وبالتالي
الاشتباك مع اربع كتائب للقسام بهدف خفض
قدراتها اما الجنوب فهناك مساله كبيره
وبعيده جدا حتى ولو حقق بعض التقدم حول
خان يونس